lâche ton arme, tu la lâches en premier Je
sais que tu es humain
Oh parce que si tu étais l'un d'entre eux, tu
m'aurais déjà tiré dessus à 1h07 du matin le
satellite Odyssey a reçu des images d'un
objet inconnu passant devant Mars, il s'est
arrêté à 250 miles au-dessus de la terre  qui
est maintenant en orbite autour de notre planète, nous les avons appelés
les autres, que veulent-ils la terre,
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils sont ici Cassie, j'ai
besoin de la terre
d'abord, ils ont pris notre pouvoir en jetant le
monde dans le chaos,
puis ils ont tout gaspillé de notre ville,
ensuite ils ont pris  nos vies
avec un virus aéroporté imparable, le
pire de tout, ils ont pris le contrôle, les
autres étaient déjà parmi nous,
exterminant tous ceux qui avaient survécu,
les autres se préparent à
la façon dont j'avais la capacité d'habiter des
hôtes humains et de contrôler leurs actions,
ils ressemblent à eux  nous
ce que nous faisons maintenant soyez là l'un pour l'autre
nous ne pouvons plus faire confiance à personne j'étais
censé me battre contre les autres je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils sont
tu étais prêt pour la fin du monde
je dois avoir mon frère
je vais l'avoir  toi là
tu sauras tout les autres
à Sam et je vais aller le chercher
nous combattons des attaques simultanées sur
la dernière nature zones politaines la 5ème
vague réussit l'
humanité sera effacée de la surface de
la terre
les autres voient  notre espoir est une faiblesse
mais ils ont tort c'est notre maison
ils ne la posséderont pas
toi